Aufwachen-Stream seit ein paar Wochen.
So richtig wach bin ich noch nicht.
Morgen, KS.
Mal erstmal was trinken hier.
Moin.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich heute
aufwachen-Stream soll.
Bin nicht so ganz fit.
Mal gucken.
Exzellent.
Was ich gerne mal ausprobieren würde, ist komplett random Themenwechsel fällt mir gerade
ein, ich mach mal kurz meine VM ein.
Ich schalt mal kurz meine VM ein.
Und zwar, was ich echt gerne mal ausprobieren würde ist Goose AI.
Wobei nicht AI, Goose.
Goose heißt es nur.
Das ist ein Open Source CLI Tool, wo man verschiedene Models ansprechen kann, um
Agentic Tasks zu erledigen. Hört sich ja immer geil an. Aber man kann damit auch lokale Models
verwenden. Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt jetzt, aber so
insgesamt. Klingt, ich bin gerade erst aufgestanden. Okay, gibt es das überhaupt? Gibt es das überhaupt
für Arch by the way. Goose. Database Migration Tool. Hier, das da. Open Source Extensible
AI Agent. Gibt es das vielleicht auch einfach so zum installieren? So für Arch Linux by the way.
Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren. Nicht, wie gesagt nicht jetzt, aber gibt es das hier zum
download debian package gibt's amd 64 debian package gibt es ja und sonst nix download
cli.sh vielleicht weiß ich nicht ob ich das ausführen sollte müssen wir mal reingucken
install goose, goose cli, goose desktop, homebrew gibt es das für linux? ah debian package rpm package
leute wer hat denn debian und wer hat denn redhead fedora sonstwas archlinux by the way ist es
guck mal das CLI kann man einfach so installieren
okay das machen wir jetzt wir installieren das jetzt komplett komplett random probieren das jetzt
einfach mal schnell aus ich mach mal kurz ein snapshot man weiß ja nie was man sich da immer
so einfängt snapshot take snapshot fuck updaten updaten müssen wir auch das ist richtig stimmt
Das ist tatsächlich, wobei, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ähm, ja, ja, ja, das machen wir.
Ich, ich, ich lösche den, warte mal, ich lösche den Snapshot einfach gleich nochmal.
So, aber, dann machen wir aufwachen streamen.
Update und Reboot.
Ich habe etwas weihnachtliche Musik an.
in der Hoffnung, dass es auch weihnachtlich
in die Playlist nicht
und Chat
was habe ich die Woche
Spannendes verpasst
gab es irgendwo Drama
also ich meine jetzt nicht
YouTube oder Twitch Drama, das interessiert mich
nicht wirklich, es gab Dings
hier, es gab doch
es gab den GitHub Actions Drama
gab es, aber das
ist eigentlich auch schon wieder vorbei.
Dass Microsoft jetzt wollte, dass man
selbst Self-Hosted Runner bezahlen muss,
was auch geil ist, ne?
Man setzt den Kram auf, installiert
selbst, betreibt selbst, bezahlt selbst
und dann soll man nochmal extra Gebühren dafür bezahlen.
Ja gut, das ist halt die Microsoft-Taktik.
Alle Leute irgendwie
zu ihren Cloud-Geschichten bringen.
Ich hab's ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
Also Microsoft, egal bei welcher Veranstaltung,
versuchen dich einfach
komplett auf AI einzuschwören.
Dazu passt ja auch, dass letztens der Microsoft-Chef gesagt hat,
also zu seinen eigenen Mitarbeitern,
wer keinen Bock auf AI hat, soll abhauen, sinngemäß.
Und auch bei uns auf der Arbeit, also da, wo ich arbeite,
jede Veranstaltung mit Microsoft, auch wenn es nicht um AI geht,
ist eigentlich eine AI-Veranstaltung.
Die sagen dann so nach dem Motto, ja, gute Frage,
aber da können wir ja auch mit AI ran.
So, eigentlich geht es um was ganz anderes, aber Microsoft laufend irgendwie versuchen sie, ihren AI-Kram unter die Nase zu reiben.
Ich sage ja nicht, dass das useless ist oder so.
Aber man kann es auch übertreiben, ne?
Microsoft übertreibt es.
Zumal ich ja echt sagen muss, also ChatGPT ist dümmer geworden.
Nö, nö, überhaupt nicht.
Überhaupt nicht.
Ich finde das enorm praktisch, AI, was Softwareentwicklung angeht.
Auch was Admin-Tasks und so angeht.
Wie oft habe ich AI schon mal gefragt, wie man einen Ad-Shop macht im 24-Stunden-Format zum Beispiel.
Weil ich mir immer das nicht merken kann, wie man das reinschreiben muss
Also, AI wird keine Jobs ersetzen bei uns
Da bin ich mir relativ sicher
Ich weiß, es sagen viele was anderes
Wobei ich da aber sagen muss, das sind meistens Leute, die nicht aus der Technik-Ecke kommen
Ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwelche Jobs ersetzen wird
Ich glaube eher, dass das einen einfach deutlich effektiver machen wird
Ich merke das ja selbst
und es mangelt ja nicht an der Arbeit, ja, wenn es irgendwie an Arbeit mangeln würde durch AI,
das könntest du sagen, okay, dann werden jetzt halt ein paar Leute rausgeschmissen,
aber erstens ist es in Deutschland ja eh sehr schwierig, da irgendwelche Leute rauszuschmeißen,
aber dann könnt ihr auch sagen, okay, wir stellen einfach nicht mehr Leute ein,
aber das sehe ich halt nicht, ich sehe halt immer noch, dass es viel, viel mehr Arbeit gibt,
als Leute diese erledigen können, das heißt es staut sich und wenn AI dazu führt,
dass es effektiver wird da geht es halt einfach nur schneller aber die arbeit geht ja nicht aus
dementsprechend glaube ich nicht dass leute rausgeschmissen werden wegen es macht dich
einfach nur effektiver guck mal wer gestern in den rast stream dabei war ich habe mir ganz viel
aus ei rausgesaugt aber ohne es einfach zu copy pasten sondern einfach so als anregung wie könnte
das denn gehen? Gut, manches habe ich
auch copy-pasted, aber dann
angepasst und so umgewurschtelt, wie ich finde,
dass es besser lesbar ist,
besser zum Projekt passt,
was auch immer, aber einfach, wenn man
beispielsweise keine Ahnung von
Rust hat, wie ich, oder nicht viel Ahnung,
ein bisschen was habe ich ja schon gemacht,
dann ist das einfach super, dass man so
Klartextfragen
an AI stellen kann und
dann sagen wir mal so zu 80,
90 Prozent Sachen
findet, die
halbwegs in die Richtung gehen, was man wissen will.
Und die restlichen 10%
kriegt man dann selbst
zusammengewurschtelt.
Das ist einfach viel effektiver, als
reiner Stack Overflow-Google.
Und wir haben trotzdem
Documentation gelesen, Stack Overflow
geguckt, also das fällt ja nicht alles weg.
Ja, aber es ist übertrieben.
Da gebe ich dir recht. Also gerade wie
Microsoft, wie aggressiv Microsoft versucht,
den kram zum vermarkten ist nervig wieso bist du nicht auf dem monte event ich
weiß nicht was es nun ist wieder ist wieder dieses grill event oder so was
vor ein paar jahren war ich habe absolut keine ahnung ich
verfolge weder youtube deutschland noch youtube twitch youtube twitch was noch
deutsch in twitch deutschland ich hoffe ich verfolge fast nichts in der
richtung sorgt aber was ich wollte jetzt updates machen updates und dann nochmal
ein snapshot machen winter event
wen juckt
gut genug leuchte mit sicherheit juckt
So.
Packet Tracer.
Packet Tracer brauchen wir nicht aktualisieren.
Guck mal hier.
Und wir müssen noch Toolbox
Jetbrain
Update machen. Das dauert jetzt ein bisschen.
Oh, also da muss man sagen,
das All Desktop Package, das lohnt sich.
Ne, wobei, ne, haha.
Das All Desktop Package lohnt sich nicht.
Weil Rider mittlerweile kostenlos ist, Pyjama kostenlos ist.
Ich glaube nur noch Golem kostet was.
Rust Rover ist glaube ich auch kostenlos.
Sea Lion ist kostenlos.
IntelliJ ist kostenlos mittlerweile.
Ich wurde positiv erwähnt in einem Oldschool COD Talk.
Aha.
Nice.
Vielleicht sollte ich ja doch mal wieder ein paar Videos machen.
Jetzt aber keine COD Videos.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal wieder einfach ein bisschen was zur Lage
Zur Lage der Nation sagen
Also nicht wirklich zur
Was so einfach Sache ist
Ein paar
Weisheiten mir zusammen
Philosophieren in irgendwelchen Videos
Wenn ich angefangen habe zu labern
Geht es ja meistens ganz gut
Da kann ich auch eine halbe Stunde am Schluck schwätzen
Neujahrsvideo
Oder Weihnachtsvideo
Weihnachtsvideo geht es ja noch nicht vorbei
Ja
Weihnachtsvideo.
Chat, ich
wollte euch jetzt mal was fragen, was ihr
davon haltet. Ich habe ein
Video gesehen auf YouTube,
wo es darum geht, es wurde mir empfohlen,
das war ein
Rhetorik-Video.
Und da ging es
darum,
was passiert,
wenn in einem, oder was man machen soll,
wenn in einem
Meeting einem die
Schuld zugeschoben wird.
Also wenn jetzt quasi
auf Meeting einer sagt, ey, was habt ihr heute Nacht
denn für einen Kack gemacht, ist alles kaputt gegangen.
So.
Und da sage ich euch jetzt mal, was
dieser Typ im Video gesagt hat
und dann könnt ihr mir ja mal sagen, ob ihr findet,
dass das eine gute Antwort ist.
Ich bin da skeptisch,
ob das so eine tolle
Antwort ist. Also,
wenn ihr in einem Meeting sitzt
und irgendeiner zu euch sagt, ey, was habt
die letzte Nacht wieder angestellt, alles kaputt gegangen,
was soll der Scheiß?
Dann soll man nicht sagen,
ich hab doch gar nichts gemacht
und auch nicht sagen,
warst du doch selber oder
ich hab überhaupt
nichts gemacht, was soll
das immer, sollst du nicht sagen,
du sollst sagen, laut diesem Rhetorik-Video,
sollst du sagen, kannst du das
nochmal wiederholen, was ich gemacht hab?
Das ist angeblich die ultimative
Antwort.
Und ich bin mir ja nicht so sicher, ob das eine gute
Antwort ist.
Das war die Fazit
von dem Video. Guck mal, heute gehen die Updates auch
schneller.
Kannst du das nochmal wiederholen, was ich gemacht habe?
So, und
da weiß ich nicht, ob das so die beste
Antwort ist.
Die Coaches,
ja. Ich weiß nicht.
Also,
also ich weiß nicht,
ich sehe mich da schon, dass ich sage, hä, wie, was,
was, was habe ich gemacht?
Aber nicht so, wie die das in diesem Video gesagt haben.
Ach ja, und dann ging es noch weiter.
Dann ging es noch weiter.
Oh, 69 Zuschauer.
Zum Glück nicht 67.
69 Zuschauer.
Ja, es ging ja noch weiter, dieses Video.
Und der Typ da, das Video meinte,
die meisten Leute können es nicht wiederholen,
Also diese Anschuldigung, ohne ihre wahren Absichten zu revealen, was auch immer das bedeuten mag.
Die Coachleute erzählen ja auch manchmal ein bisschen kryptische Sachen.
Und dann als nächstes, was man sagen soll, ist, mal gucken, genau, was erhoffst du dir von diesem, was für einen Ausgang erhoffst du dir von dem Gespräch?
Was soll man da noch sagen, wenn die Diskussion weitergeht?
Ich weiß nicht.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich habe ja schon so ein paar solcher Rhetorik-Videos geguckt.
Manche Sachen sind auch echt gut, muss man nicht sagen.
Ich habe früher öfters mal, wie hieß der, Redefabrik oder so geguckt.
Gucke ich aber in letzter Zeit auch nicht mehr.
Da sind dann teilweise schon ganz gute Sachen dabei.
aber oftmals sind diese ultimative tipp video für das ist oftmals einfach da sehe ich mich
nicht dass das ernsthaft sagen zu können so updates durch moment
Warum habe ich jetzt rebooted? Wir haben überhaupt kein Körnlapet gemacht.
Der Reboot war komplett umsonst, Alter.
Bewerbungsgespräche.
Da muss ich sagen, ich habe mich nicht, also ich habe mich null vorbereitet auf mein letztes Bewerbungsgespräch.
Und es lief super.
Soll ich das Wasser trinken oder nicht?
Und? Und? Was ist die Antwort da drauf?
Sollst du oder sollst du nicht?
Das interessiert mich jetzt.
Was sagt der Rhetorik-Coach?
Soll man oder soll man nicht?
Also mein letztes Bewerbungsgespräch lief super.
Ich habe mich null drauf vorbereitet.
Das liegt aber nicht daran, weil ich irgendwie der...
geborene Bewerbungsgespräch-Typ bin oder so.
Ganz im Gegenteil.
Hattest du das Gespräch mit HR oder Kollegen?
Ich hatte mein Bewerbungsgespräch mit einem von HR und mit meinem Teamleiter.
Dem damaligen Teamleiter.
Kollegen, nichts, war zu spät.
Die waren schon alle weg.
Sonst wäre ich da auch nochmal vorbeigegangen.
Ja, das lief super.
Das lief aber aus einem Grund super.
Oder aus einem hauptsächlichen Grund super.
Dass ich nicht auf den Job angewiesen war.
Erstens.
Ich war doppelt nicht darauf angewiesen.
Erstens, ich hatte noch einen Job
Auf den ich aber
Wo ich aber weg wollte, aber ich hatte noch einen
Und ich hatte da auch noch nicht gekündigt oder so
Und das zweite war
Ich hatte schon bei einem
Anderen Arbeitgeber einen Vertrag
In der Post, bei dem ich hätte
Direkt anfangen können nächstes Jahr
Also nicht nächstes Jahr, also
2023 dann
Ähm
Der mir auch ganz gut gefallen hat
Also ich hatte überhaupt gar keinen Druck bei meinem Vorstellungsgespräch, da irgendwie da jetzt was zu machen, was ich nicht bin.
Und dementsprechend lief das super.
Ich habe übrigens den Fiat Champ gezeigt im Vorstellungsgespräch.
Damals habe ich noch gedacht, ich entwickle daran eifrig weiter, aber...
Das fanden sie richtig nice.
Die fanden es auch richtig cool, dass ich ein Gitterprofil mitgeschickt habe.
Und ist als Nichtentwickler.
Gitterprofil kam gut an.
Ne.
Habe ich nicht gemacht.
Habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Wobei wir haben.
Doch.
Einen Workshop habe ich gemacht.
Das war aber so inzwischen.
Das war ein Kommunikationsworkshop, wo es darum ging, dass nicht alle Sachen immer so ankommen, wie sie gemeint sind.
Weil Leute unterschiedlich denken.
So sinngemäß ging das.
Da haben wir auch komische Spielchen gemacht.
Da haben wir so einen Turm gebaut.
Ich habe vergessen, wie dieses Spiel hieß.
Tower of Power
oder sowas hieß das. Diese Dinge haben ja immer
rübelsbescheuerte Namen. Warte mal.
Warte mal. Ich such das mal kurz.
Tower of Power
hieß das, glaube ich.
Ne, die weine ich nicht.
Spiel.
Ja.
Genau. Genau.
Dieses Teil haben wir gemacht!
Wonka ist genau das.
Genau dieses...
Ja, ja, doch, doch.
Ist okay.
Genau.
Alter!
What the fuck?
Das sind ein paar Stücke Holz, Alter.
Warum kostet das 399 Euro?
WTF?
Okay, da sieht man schon,
das ist irgend so ein komisches
Teambuilding-Coaching-Zeug.
Das muss teuer sein.
Also, was man damit macht, ist folgendes.
Guck mal hier.
Du musst einen Turm bauen.
Also es gibt...
Das ist total hängengeflieben, aber trotzdem.
Es gibt solche Holzstücke hier.
So.
Die sind schräg und haben jeweils immer so eine Einkerbung.
Was man jetzt machen muss, ist...
Alle Leute stellen sich im Kreis um die Holzstücke.
So.
Ach, guck mal, es gibt sogar ein Video Tower of Power.
Schaut euch das mal an.
Ein Tower of Power Video.
Genau.
Genau, so funzt das.
Guck.
Du musst im Kreis stehen, alle kriegen so ein Ding, so eine Schnur, so ein Seil.
In der Mitte hängt so eine Art Kran und du musst mit dem Kran,
mit dem Kran musst du dann diese Teile hochheben und aufeinandersetzen,
so dass es einen Turm ergibt.
Und das ist ein Kommunikations-Workshop-Ding,
Weil du musst ja dabei kommunizieren, wie du es am besten machst.
Warum dieses Ding jetzt 400 Euro kostet, ist mir auch schleierhaft.
Genau, so, das haben wir da gemacht.
Das haben wir da gemacht, unter anderem in unserem Kommunikationsworkshop.
Na, weil du da kommunizieren musst.
Guck, du siehst doch schon, wie happy sie alle sind,
dass sie kommunizieren dürfen bei diesem Game.
Okay, jetzt haben sie sich aber blöd angestellt.
So, das ist der Tower of Power.
Das haben wir da gemacht.
Dann haben sie uns noch irgendwas erzählt über verschiedene Farben, die die Leute sind.
Das ist auch so ein super umstrittenes Modell, was eigentlich keine wirklich, wie soll man sagen, so psychologische Grundlage hat und eigentlich total Blödsinn ist.
Aber das wird gerne auf solchen Workshops erzählt.
So Leute kriegen dann Farben so grün, rot, gelb, blau und sowas.
Und das soll angeblich was über die Persönlichkeit aussagen.
Naja, das schiebe ich mal eher in die Ecke von so ein bisschen Esoterik-Blub.
Genau, ja. Aber das machen die gerne. Das machen die aber gerne, diese Farbengeschichte auf diesen Workshops.
So, habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet?
Reboot.
Ja, wir haben alles geupdatet.
Wenn ich alles geupdatet habe, dann kann ich jetzt ja das machen,
was ich eigentlich machen wollte, noch einen Snapshot.
So.
Ach, Bernd, du meinst als Farbe?
Ne.
Ach, hast du dich gedrückt, ja?
Ich finde, ab und zu kann man sowas schon machen.
Man darf bloß nicht erwarten, dass da irgendwie so eine super krasse Erkenntnis bei rauskommt.
Ja, ganz, ganz genau.
Das ist wirklich...
Das ist...
Ups, jetzt bin ich gegen das Mikrofon gekommen.
Das ist Hardcore-Cake-Alu.
Cake-Alu.
Ah ja.
So, Leute.
Was machen wir denn heute?
Haben wir ein paar gescheite Videos,
die wir gucken können?
Was ist das?
Vom Kellernerd zum Beratungsprofi.
Karriere und Gehalt.
Ach ne, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das Wichtigste habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Wir müssen
Getuptrends gucken.
So, jetzt löschen wir die alten Snapshots erst einmal.
Hoffentlich dauert das jetzt nicht wieder eine halbe Stunde.
Die Windows 11 Crisis.
Ist das da?
Crisis, das?
Oh ne, please.
Mehr AI?
Lass mich raten, mehr AI.
Microsoft, das muss mehr AI sein.
Windows is now your canvas for AI and Agents.
Ich dreh durch.
Nein, please, lass mich in Ruhe.
Muss das sein?
Ihr könnt mich mal Microsoft, ey.
Ach ja, oh, oh, oh, chat, chat, mir fällt gerade was auf.
Moment, Moment, ich habe doch Windows neu installiert.
Moment, Moment, ähm.
Windows Recall
Check if enabled
Ich muss gucken, dass Recall aus ist
Dieser Shit ist ja vielleicht sonst am Start
Äh, okay, das muss ich als Admin starten
Monks Recall
Es ist installiert
Shit, aber State
Moment, was?
State? Ne, ist es nicht installiert
State disabled with payload removed
Das bedeutet, es ist ausgeschaltet
und nicht installiert, oder?
Moin, I am Nubi
Das heißt, es ist uninstalled, oder?
Dieser Shit, Alter. Ich will den ganzen AI-Kram von Microsoft nicht. Wenn ich AI-Krampel will, dann kümmere ich mich selbst drum.
Wenn ich das hier höre, dann kriege ich schon wieder Anfälle.
AI. AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Das Video war ein Erkennung von Microsoft vor ein paar Wochen. Sie machen es klar, dass AI jetzt am Vordergrund von Windows ist.
Windows 11, they say, is becoming an agentic operating system.
Agentic, the latest buzzword for autonomous AI.
Soon your PC will make decisions on your behalf, with the help of a built-in AI.
Ihr könnt mich einfach in Ruhe lassen mit dem Scheiß, Microsoft.
Shortly after the event, Pavan Davuluri, the...
Dort wo es Sinn macht, beispielsweise im Editor oder in der IDE oder so,
oder bei Fragen, wenn es ums Programmieren geht, da benutze ich das doch schon.
Aber so und wann und wie und wo ich will und nicht gezwungenermaßen, vor allem, dass dann alles wahrscheinlich gescannt wird, verwertet wird, verarbeitet wird, an Microsoft geschickt wird, noch mehr als jetzt schon ist.
Was Copilot bei LG Fernsehern? Moment, Moment, es gibt Copilot bei Fernsehern? Was macht der denn?
Was soll man damit machen?
Mich wundert es ja auch noch, dass mein Nvidia Shield noch keinen AI-Modus hat
Wobei, wobei, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher
Ich hab schon eine Weile nicht mehr geupdatet
Ich muss mal kurz gucken
Hallo?
Äh
Mein Firefox ist dead.
Kill all Firefox.
Ich weiß nicht, warum mein Firefox dead war.
Nvidia Shield TV.
AI.
Upscaling.
Okay.
Hier bleibe ich noch.
Ich bleibe noch verschont vor AI.
Aber im Shield TV.
Aber dieser Tag hier, Alter.
Ich hab da so keinen Bock drauf.
Ich hab mein Fernseher auch nicht
mit dem Internet verbunden.
Also, ich hab ja
seit ein paar Jahren so einen Sony
boah, keine Ahnung wie das
Ding heißt, mit Android
TV drauf.
Und den hab ich nicht einmal im Internet verbunden.
Ich habe da mein Shield-TV dran gestöpselt und das wird benutzt. Fertig.
Ich habe ja eh ein bisschen advanceres Setup fürs Wohnzimmer.
Also ich habe den Fernseher mit Android-TV drauf, nur dass das Android-TV da drauf halt überhaupt nichts macht.
Ich benutze einfach nur den HDMI-Eingang.
Dann habe ich eine Playstation 4 dran, falls man doch mal irgendwelche Blu-Rays oder DVDs gucken will.
Und ich habe mein Shield-TV dran.
Shield TV hat dann die ganzen Apps von Amazon bis Netflix, Join und weiß nicht mehr, die ganzen Streaming-Apps.
Hat Kodi drauf.
Kodi mit TV-Headend-Client.
Und dann habe ich noch eine VU, wie heißt das Ding? VU Plus oder sowas.
So ein Ding habe ich noch.
Da habe ich den TV-Headend-Server drauf.
Weil das Ding hat 8-fach DVB-C-Tuner.
und da habe ich einen TV Headend Server
drauf, wogegen sich das Shield TV dann
verbindet. Hat nämlich den großen Vorteil,
wenn eins davon kaputt geht,
dann funzt das andere noch.
Und meine Aufnahmen
sind, naja,
meine nicht, also
die von meiner Mutter, die Aufnahmen,
ich benutze das so gut wie nie, sind sicher.
Also, das finde ich ein ganz
gutes Setup für Fernsehstells.
Das Entfernen von,
Was das Entfernen von Windows Recall beschädigt den Dateiexplorer.
Was?
Moment, Moment, ich muss mir das hier copy-pasten, weil es wieder nicht richtig gecheckt hat.
Das Entfernen von Windows...
Moment, kurz Musik anmachen.
Das Entfernen von Windows Recall beschädigt den Dateiexplorer.
Die Recall genannte Windows 11 Funktion sorgt jetzt seit ihrer Ankündigung für Aufregung hinsichtlich Themen wie Datenschutz und Privatsphäre.
Nun ist es erneut soweit.
Denn es ist und bleibt unklar, ob das Deaktivieren von Recall möglich und durchführbar ist.
Ja Moment, es ist ja deaktiviert bei mir.
Und das ist von 2024, das ist ja schon wieder outdated.
Hast du Jellyfin? Nö.
Ich streame keine drunter geladenen Sachen
Ich streame nur über Streaming-Apps, wo ich ein Abo hab
Oder Sachen, die ganz normal über DVB-C aufgenommen wurden
Und da auch nur, was das hergibt ohne irgendwelche Hacks
Ne, ist wirklich so
was es ohne irgendwelche Hex hergibt.
Das heißt, ich gucke auch Sat.1, RTL
und sowas, wenn denn mal,
gucke ich in SD, nicht in HD.
Weil sonst müsste man irgendwelche
Smartcard-Hex und Gedöns machen.
Ich habe noch nicht mal eine Smartcard,
die sich dafür eignet.
Mir zu blöd.
Ich bezahle Streaming-Dienste,
bezahle ich
Amazon Prime
Ich habe auf Prime
ab und zu mal
ein Apple
wie heißt das, Apple TV Abo gehabt
nur manche
gibt es die ein oder andere Serie, die ganz nice war
aber das kündige ich dann immer wieder
ab und zu habe ich ein Netflix Abo
wenn ich da mal was gucken will, wird dann aber auch
immer nur aktiviert und direkt
nach dem Abschließen wieder gekündigt
Und ansonsten
Guck ich da eigentlich nix großartig
Meine Mutter
Guckt über
DVB-C Fernsehen und nimmt da Sachen auf
Die benutzt die ARD Mediathek
Die ZDF Mediathek
Join
Guckt ab und zu irgendwelches olles Zeug da in Sat.1
Und ich glaub das war's
Damit kommt man gut hin
Also Silo habe ich nicht geguckt, Severance habe ich geguckt.
Ich fand die erste Staffel Severance richtig nice, auch wenn fast nichts passiert ist.
Die zweite fand ich nicht mehr so gut.
Die zweite war super in die Länge gezogen und es ist nichts passiert.
Und die wollen ja noch mehr machen.
Ich habe eigentlich gehofft, es ist am Ende der zweiten Staffel mal ordentlich abgeschlossen, aber nee, ist es nicht.
Aber ich spoilere jetzt nicht.
So, wir sollten mal gucken, was auf GitHub so trendet.
So, es trendet.
Exo, run your own AI-Klassen.
Nein, Gott!
Nein, Gott, bitte nicht!
Nein!
Ich scroll mal weiter.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Deep Audit.
Okay, China-Chinesen-Kram.
Keine Ahnung.
Whatever.
Okay, lass uns das mal kurz übersetzen.
Exo is nice.
Oh, kennst du das?
Translate to English.
Okay, was haben wir hier?
An AI-Hacking-Team. Jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen, die China-Chinesen, Alter.
Von welcher Sprache ist es überhaupt übersetzt? Keine Ahnung.
An AI-Hacking-Team for everyone.
Chinas first open source multi-agent system.
Das connectet mehrere PCs, wenn das Model nicht auf einen passt.
Oh, das ist tatsächlich ganz gut.
Mal angenommen, ich habe nur 64 GB RAM und 24 GB Grafik RAM und ich habe noch einen zweiten Rechner mit 32 GB, dann könnte man da auch ein bisschen was Größeres laufen lassen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber wahrscheinlich relativ lahm, oder?
Also das juckt mich jetzt wenig.
Laut, klot, wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Co-Pilot?
Alter, es ist ja nur AI-Zeug, was trendet.
Payload?
Was auch immer.
Minis?
Klingt auch nach AI.
No description?
Ja, AI.
AI.
IPTV.
Achso, ist irgendjemand im Chat gerade gefragt,
ob ich auf IPTV umsteigen will?
Nö.
Ich habe da...
Ich habe den Kabelanschluss mit einem Achtfach-Tuner dran.
Das wird es für die nächsten Jahre noch gut tun.
Und da muss ich keine Gedanken drüber machen,
wenn das Internet mal Probleme hat und so.
Hier ein sehr gutes Video.
Aha.
Ein Video zu was?
Zu...
Apple just dropped a Game Changer.
Das geht doch schon eine Weile,
dass man Mac-Kisten zusammenstöpseln kann.
Für AI-Stells.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Grafikkarten.
Ich habe immer nur Ahnung von PC-Hardware,
wenn ich mir einen neuen kaufen will.
Schauen wir heute das C++ Video.
Ich würde gerne das C++ Video gucken.
Das Problem ist nur, das C++ Video ist 2 Stunden 9 Minuten lang.
Aber das ist ein gutes Video.
Das fängt zumindest...
Das gucken wir jetzt aber nicht.
Das fängt zumindest schon gut an.
Wir gucken uns mal die ersten 30 Sekunden an, dass ihr seht, dass das ein gutes Video ist.
Das ist ein echt gutes Video.
Und am besten ist,
dass
Das sind viele Sachen, die ich auch kacke finde, greift er in dem Video auf.
Er benutzt KQ, das werte das Video schon mal auf, das ist von mir.
Das blende ich hier ein, das ist nicht aus dem Video.
Schau dir mal
RDMA an
Remote Direct Memory Access
Was? Warum?
Wie jetzt?
So, wir gucken jetzt nochmal kurz weiter
Weil in den GitHub Trends war ja wirklich
nur Schrott drin, was mich überhaupt nicht interessiert hat.
Schauen wir mal. Ach, das ist heute.
Ich habe auf heute
eingestellt. Ja, das ist falsch.
This week muss ich gucken, was trendet.
Okay.
Wir können das Video mal aufmachen.
Und das hier.
Gucken wir mal.
Was ist mit Weihnachtsstream?
Und wir schauen es da.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Zur Weihnachten eine Runde
Massive Riesen C++ Rant.
Ich glaube, das ist genau das,
was wir brauchen zu Weihnachten, oder?
Also ernst gemeint.
Ich glaube, das brauchen wir zu Weihnachten.
So, also.
Was trendet denn diese Woche?
AI.
Oh was ist das?
Eine Rust-Database kompatibel mit SQLite.
Das ist tatsächlich mal ein interessantes Projekt.
AI.
Vibe Workflow Platform.
Was zum Teufel ist eine Vibe Workflow Platform?
Das ist auch AI.
Aber ich kann mir so nichts darunter vorstellen.
Ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen. AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, Alter. Es ist ein Projekt, nicht AI diese Woche.
WTF.
Was ist eine Vibe-Workflow-Plattform?
Das ist sowas wie IFTTT oder N8N, nur mit Workflows, die AI generiert werden oder wie?
Okay, who cares?
Torso ist in in-process SQL-Database kompatibel mit SQLite.
This software is beta.
Ja, blazingly fast written in Rust ist es aber.
Moment.
Ach, das gibt es auch in...
Gibt es auch für verschiedene...
Sprachen.
Gibt es ein Example?
So, würde mich einfach mal interessieren, wie es ausschaut.
Example?
Examples.
JavaScript?
MonkHS?
Ich dachte Rust.
Blazingly Fast.
Warum JavaScript?
MonkaS?
Okay, ist es im Endeffekt
sq lite nur in rust oder wie
examples
guck mal wie das in rust aussieht
zeig mal her
erste mal
dreimal so lang wie das
javascript beispiel
also
zeig mal her wie sieht es aus
bilder new local memory
ok jetzt in memory datenbank
bla bla bla
connect
execute, ja das ist doch relativ
übersichtlich oder, also das sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus
das könnten wir mal ausprobieren, jetzt wenn wir eh gerade
so ein bisschen uns mit
Rust beschäftigen
ein extremely fast
Python Type Checker
wurde mir gerade im Chat
geschickt und was
ich dachte das nice an Python ist
was viele so nice finden, dass es eben nicht so richtig statisch typisiert ist.
Und was macht jetzt der Type Checker?
Da bin ich zu wenig Python Kenner für, das zu checken.
Sie ist ja super leise gerade.
ja so leute was gucken wir uns jetzt an das ding ist einfach viel schneller ja
aber für warms was benutze ich denn prinzipiell ein type checker
Ja, OV kenne ich.
Das ist
irgendwann ein neues Python-Tool-Ding.
Für alles mögliche.
Juryoka
ist pleite. Na, dann.
So, das gucken wir uns an. Vom Keller-Nerd
zum Beratungsprofi. Karriere und
Geld im IT-Consulting.
Ich hoffe, der macht
mehr als den ganzen Tag Excel-Schuppen.
schubsen schuppen excel schuppen excel schubsen
schau mal mal kurz die musik aus musik machen wir auf extra tab also
auf geht's
was was wie was ist darf was nicht in die cloud
Ich glaube, es geht los.
Wobei, das ist ja mittlerweile auch schon wieder der Trend.
Dieses Cloud-Only, was noch ein paar Jahre lang jetzt ja immer versucht wurde und propagiert wurde,
ist auch schon wieder ein bisschen auf dem Rückzug, weil man festgestellt hat,
okay, für alles ist es halt doch nicht so geil.
Aber das braucht immer ein bisschen.
Leute mit ein bisschen technischem Verständnis haben das von Anfang an gesagt,
aber das wollte man dann nicht hören.
Ja, du hattest bessere Beförderungschancen, wenn du voll auf den Cloud-Hype vor ein paar Jahren aufgesprungen bist.
Obwohl du wusstest, dass es Blödsinn ist, anstatt da sinnvolle Sachen zu machen.
Was sind vielleicht Hochsicherheitszonen und was darf nicht in die Cloud?
Das Schlimmste, was passieren könnte, ist, dass ich einen Kunden falsch berate und deswegen geht es eben darum...
Das könnte ja bei einem Berater niemals passieren.
Frühzeitig das Verständnis dafür zu schaffen.
B2B-Sharing geht nicht, oder wie?
Was habt ihr noch so?
Ich muss noch kurz zum ***.
Wer hat ein Thema?
Bis wann?
Weil heute ist es schwierig so.
Sag mal doch ein bisschen was für Eskalation.
Servus zusammen, mein Name ist Elmar.
Ich bin 34 Jahre alt, arbeite als Lead Consultant für das Thema Modern Workplace.
Und was wir unter moderner Arbeit...
Modern Workplace.
Verstehen, das zeige ich euch heute.
Ich jogge morgens einfach gern, um auf mein Level zu kommen.
Da bin ich danach kurz...
11 Kilometer, ordentlich.
Ich bin schon eine Weile nicht mehr 11 Kilometer gerannt.
Bestimmt schon einen Monat her.
Also, aktuell bin ich ein bisschen faul.
Ich mache meine 5,5 Kilometer Runde und dann ist Ruhe.
Reicht mir.
Ich bin konzentriert für die Arbeit und ruhig bin.
und nicht die ganze Zeit hibbelig durch mein ADHS irgendwie am Schreibtisch sitze und rumrennen möchte.
Bechtle ist ein IT-System.
Die kenn ich.
Im Haus.
Wir verkaufen Lizenzen, Hardware und eben auch Dienstleistungen in Form von Beratung
oder Umsetzung.
Beruflich bin ich Lead Consultant für das Thema Modern Workplace und ich berate
Die haben bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber immer die alte Hardware bekommen und dann irgendwie zu Geld gemacht.
...Kunden bei ihrer Microsoft 365 bzw. ihrer modernen Arbeit.
Wenn ich das jetzt nicht durcheinander bringe.
Das reine Einführen von so einem Tool, von so einem Produkt schafft noch keine moderne Arbeit.
Moment, was?
... eine Arbeit ist, was im Kopf der Leute stattfinden muss, dass man diese Produkte richtig zusammenverwendet.
Ich bin heute viel im Mikro...
Hä? Den Satz habe ich nicht kapiert. Moment. Das war so ein typischer Beratungssatz. Nochmal.
Gibt es da überhaupt was zu verstehen?
... beziehungsweise ihre moderne Arbeitsstrategie. Das reine Einführen von so einem Tool, von so einem Produkt.
Was denn für ein Produkt? Ich checke es nicht.
... Modern Workplace.
Modern Workplace.
... bei ihrer Microsoft 365, beziehungsweise...
Ach, 305, oh, AI.
Das ist ja moderne Arbeitsstrategie.
Das reine Einführen von so einem Tool, von so einem Produkt schafft noch keine moderne Arbeit.
Office.
Moderne Arbeit ist was, was im Kopf der Leute stattfinden muss, dass man diese Produkte richtig zusammen verwendet.
Ich bin heute viele Meetings unterwegs und gar nicht viel am Schreibtisch am Sitzen.
Ja gut, das ist ja glaube ich bei Beratern, also ich meine, das ist bei mir schon so, bei Beratern ist es wahrscheinlich noch mehr.
Und zwar habe ich jetzt um 9 den Kundenworkshop.
Dann freue ich mich auf meinen Nachmittag mit meinem Team quasi, was ich heute habe.
Unseren Surefix.
Guten Nachmittag.
Und dann habe ich nachher noch einen...
Das ist aber...
Nicht viel.
Ich meine, wenn er jetzt fünf Surefixe am Tag hätte...
Kickoff.
Ah, der geht noch weiter.
Und da bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt. Da lasse ich mich mal überraschen.
Also unsere Kunden sind alle Mittelständler und Industriefirmen hier im Umkreis.
Wir in Freiburg kennen uns hier besonders gut mit diesem modernen Arbeitsplatz aus.
Das bedeutet einmal eben mit modernen Geräten.
Ob die auch zu allem User-Stories machen?
Gerätemanagement, da kennen wir sehr viele unterschiedliche Produkte und beraten da auch Unternehmen,
die zum Beispiel in Hamburg oder in Köln sitzen.
Ich habe noch was Süßes besorgt. Ich esse es ja sowieso nicht.
Es ist sehr lustig, dass du immer Süßigkeiten besorgst und sie nicht futterst.
Das ist Absicht.
Der Kunde ist Halsstrup Walcher.
Die mussten bestimmt gefragt werden, ob man sie erwähnen darf in dem Beitrag.
Das machen sie Servomotoren. Wir waren bei denen schon in der Produktion.
Warum machen wir das eigentlich?
Und zwar einmal, um Dienstleistungen zu platzieren, weil wir Dienstleistungen am Ende Geld verdienen.
Und um natürlich auch die Zeit.
By the way, diese Stühle, ne?
Diese Stühle sind so hardcore unbequem.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum es die gibt.
Ist die so schlimm?
Mit Dienstleistungen am Ende Geld verdienen und um natürlich auch Lizenzen zu platzieren.
Also wenn der Kunde mehr Microsoft 365 Features nutzt, braucht er eine größere Lizenz.
Und die kriegen mehr Geld.
Und wer die Lizenz über uns bezieht, verdienen wir da natürlich auch dran.
Exzellent.
Wir bekommen ein Jahresfixgehalt in Höhe von 78.000 Euro.
Dann hätte ich theoretisch die Möglichkeit, mein Jahreszielgehalt zu erreichen.
Das wären 85.000 Euro.
Die bekomme ich, wenn ich 100% der Ziele erreiche.
Und dann gibt es bei uns noch eine Top-Performance.
Oh, das ist für das High-Performer-Crisis-Mindset.
Wenn wir also überperformen, habe ich die Möglichkeit bis zu 92.000 Euro Jahresgehalt zu bekommen.
Kommt rein, macht es euch gemütlich.
Ich bringe meinen eigenen Tisch.
Bring your own table.
Loslegen.
Das sieht schon so unbequem aus, diese Stühle und Tische.
Das ist viel zu tief.
Also, was ist eure Zielsetzung?
Unsere Zielsetzung ist eigentlich die optimale Zusammenarbeit.
Bewusstsein über die Herausforderungen in der modernen Arbeit mit Marks und Trailer,
wie in diesem ganzen...
Okay, das ist halt typisches Beraterspeak.
...Arbeit bei uns in der Organisation.
Wie schaffen wir es überhaupt, so etwas aufzusetzen und ins Unternehmen reinzubringen nachher?
Die IT möchte vielleicht möglichst viel vorgeben und die Unternehmensleitung möchte vielleicht möglichst wenig Vorgaben haben,
möchte aber am Ende trotzdem sicher sein.
Und was sind vielleicht Hochsicherheitszonen?
Also ihr habt ja auch Produktionsdaten.
Was darf in die Cloud und was darf nicht in die Cloud oder wie darf es in die Cloud?
Das Schlimmste, was passieren könnte, ist, dass ich einen Kunden falsch berate.
Jetzt mal eine blöde Frage.
Warum genau brauchst du dafür einen Berater?
Das habe ich noch nicht so genau verstanden.
Was, was, also, also...
wo ist da jetzt genau der Vorteil von,
das mit einem Berater zu machen?
Weil ich meine, man könnte sich doch einfach mal
einen Account anlegen und sich das mal angucken,
gerade wenn das irgendwelche kleinen
und mittelständischen Unternehmen sind.
Erstmal so gucken, okay, ist das was für uns?
Eignet sich das für uns?
Bisschen rumprobieren.
Man hat ja durchaus auch die ein oder anderen IT-Leute wahrscheinlich,
die sich damit auskennen.
Irgendeiner muss den Kram am Ende dann auch managen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
der einzige Grund, warum man das über
einen Berater macht, ist,
dass man sich rausreden kann am Ende,
wenn es Mist ist, dass man sagen kann,
ja, der Berater war Mist, oder dass man sagen kann,
oh, wir verklagen jetzt den Berater oder so,
aber es halt nicht funktionieren wird.
So genau, ansonsten frage ich,
warum genau, also,
warum braucht man da einen Berater?
...warte er daraus eine falsche Entscheidung trifft und daraus wirklich einen Sicherheitsvorfall beim Kunden entsteht oder er irgendwo Geld verliert.
Jetzt bin ich gerade gar nicht so technisch aware bei euch. Was habt ihr nochmal als Telefonlösung?
Ja, ich bin auch nicht so technisch aware.
Okay, die ist gekoppelt, sehr cool. Also ich komme klassisch aus der Softwareentwicklung. Ich bin der Keller-Nerd gewesen.
Wobei, ich darf da nichts sagen. Ich denglische hier ja auch immer rum, das ist ja nicht mehr feierlich. Ich ziehe das zurück. Das hätte ich genauso sagen können.
Und ich habe aber nach ein paar Jahren festgestellt, das fühle ich einfach nicht. Ich entwickle gerne immer noch für zu Hause, zu Hause meine Hausautomatisierung, aber ich möchte es nicht im beruflichen Bereich machen.
Ein Home-Automation-Enjoyer.
So, okay.
Jetzt ist er mir gleich sympathischer.
Ehemaliger Softwareentwickler, das heißt, er hat auch Ahnung von der,
ich meine jetzt nicht unbedingt von der Office 365,
aber zumindest ein bisschen von Technik, Kram.
und da möchte ich lieber beraten.
Da bin ich lieber der kommunikative
Dummschwätzer am Ende.
Ich glaube, es gibt kaum
Softwareentwickler, die das gerne
machen und
die sagen, ach, ich würde lieber in die Beratung
gehen. Da ist er echt die Ausnahme.
Oder es hat ihm nie richtig gefallen, vielleicht.
Der hat immer gesagt, so richtig
Bock habe ich da nicht drauf.
Ich hab's in der Schule nicht leicht, oder ich hab's meinen Eltern, glaub ich, auch nicht
leicht gemacht, weil die mussten mit den Konsequenzen leben, weil ich einfach durch mein ADHS und
durch meine Lese-Rechtschreib-Schwäche doch häufig angeeckt bin.
Ich wüsste nicht, wo ich heute wäre ohne sie.
Gut, danke, dass ihr hier wart.
Antje, ich muss noch kurz zum ***, der hat ein Thema.
Kunde will weitermachen, Kunde hat...
Sebastian und Juri haben gesehen, dass es den Bedarf bei ihnen im Unternehmen gibt und dass wir den befriedigen können.
Jetzt hoffen wir natürlich, dass sie das Angebot, was sie von uns bekommen haben, zeitnah bestellen.
So, wir haben von einem Kunden eine Liste mit Fragen bekommen.
Also da hätte ich ja keinen Bock drauf.
Mir geht es ja schon bei mir auf den Keks, dass ich gefühlt 70% meiner Zeit miete.
Aber das wäre mir dann echt zu krass.
Der macht ja den ganzen Tag wirklich nichts außer mieten.
Datenschutz und rechtlichen Implikationen.
Gut, Beratung würde ich eh im Leben nicht machen, aber das wäre mir echt zu viel.
... zur Nutzung von Microsoft 365.
Und vor allem dann auch noch mit so einem Kack wie Microsoft 365 sich den ganzen Tag beschäftigen.
Das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Nicht nur den ganzen Tag mieten und dumm Zeug labern müssen,
nein, auch noch für Microsoft 365.
Ich glaube, der Kunde wartet halt schon seit vier Wochen auf eine Rückmeldung
zu in seinen Augen einer relativ trivialen Frage.
Aber in unseren Augen ist die Frage halt nicht trivial.
und ich denke jetzt wird das Thema beim Kunden hochgekocht sein nochmal.
Bis wann? Weil heute ist schwierig so.
Ich kann jetzt gucken, dass ich es irgendwann heute Abend, morgen früh dir eine Liste geben kann.
Sag mal doch ein bisschen was in Eskalation.
Warum muss der vier Wochen warten?
Wir werden jetzt erstmal kurz ein Daily machen, dass wir darüber sprechen, was haben wir für aktuelle Kundensituationen.
Das ist aber nicht Agile, die sitzen alle. Das geht aber nicht. Das muss agiles Stand-up sein. Da wird nicht gesessen.
ich komme zu spät tut mir leid das team was ich lateral führen darf ist sagen wir interdisziplinär
aufgebaut wir haben da personen im team was ein team ohne sagen ein team führen ohne weisungsbefugnis
wie sollen das funktionieren jetzt mal ernsthaft wie willst du das verstehe ich nicht wie willst du
ein team führen ohne weisungsbefugnis da geht es ja zum beispiel unter also also eines der sachen
mit denen sich mein Chef relativ oft beschäftigen muss, ist zum Beispiel, Team A will was von mir, Team B will was von mir und ich sage dann, also Leute, gleichzeitig kann ich das nicht machen und beides sind der Meinung, das muss jetzt gemacht werden.
Dann sag ich dann, ey Leute, geht zu meinem Chef,
fragt den, was wichtiger ist
oder was ich machen soll. Dann sagt mein Chef,
Max, du musst das machen von Team A.
Aber wie soll das ohne Weisungsbefugnis
gehen? Weil da könnte ich einfach sagen,
ja, okay, dann mach ich das, was Team B
will. Hä?
Das verstehe ich nicht, wie das von uns...
Bei welchem Consulting?
Und bei Bechtle ist das...
Aber das verstehe ich nicht, wie das ohne Weisungsbefugnis
geht.
Ja, oder dass der zum Beispiel auch mal sagt, ey, guck mal, am Wochenende muss einer Rufbereitschaft machen für den und den Service und alle sagen, ach nee, mach ich nicht, kein Bock. Dann muss da halt irgendjemand rausgucken, der sagt, ey, guck mal, Max, du hast jetzt schon seit drei Monaten nichts gemacht, mach du das doch mal am Wochenende.
ich muss ja sagen, mein Chef verpackt die Sachen
immer sehr gut, ich fühle mich
da nie irgendwie übergangen
oder irgendwie
schlecht behandelt oder so, also das ist der beste
Chef, den ich je hatte
den ich aktuell habe
der würde das anders verpacken
der würde dann sagen, sag mal Max, kannst du
nicht am Wochenende, so und wenn der da schon so
fragt, dann würde ich natürlich sagen, ja klar, kein Problem
kann ich machen
schaut dazu, ne, der kennt man scheinbar nicht
Das kennen eh auf der neuen Arbeit nicht so viele Leute
Das ja
Was auch ganz gut ist
Achso, du meinst, weil ich jetzt rumgeschleimt hab
Ne, das mein ich ernst
Das, das, das mein ich ernst
Ähm, also wenn ich das mal vergleiche
Aktueller Arbeitgeber mit
Letztem Arbeitgeber, was Führungskräfte angeht
Man merkt, also bei meinem
Letzten Arbeitgeber war das so
Wartet mal kurz, ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen
Bei meinem letzten Arbeitgeber war das so, da wurdest du Führungskraft, also ich muss das anders erzählen.
In normalen Unternehmen würde ich mal sagen, ist es eher so, dass es mehr Leute gibt, die gerne diesen Führungskraft-Karriereweg einschlagen würden, als es Stellen gibt.
Bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber war es so, da war das so beschissen, Führungskraft zu sein,
dass du nur Führungskraft würdest, wenn du nicht bei drei auf dem Baum warst, wenn sie danach gesucht haben.
Das wollte niemand machen.
Und das kann ich auch verstehen, weil die haben dort die Leute immer komplett ins kalte Wasser geworfen,
alleine stehen lassen, keine Vorbereitung gegeben und alles.
Das war Schrott.
Das war Schrott. Deswegen kann ich nicht sagen, dass sich meine alten Chefs keine Mühe gegeben haben, aber das war in dem Unternehmen halt einfach schwierig, Führungskraft zu sein.
Und jetzt in dem Neuen, wo ich bin, also neu ist ja auch, ich bin ja auch schon jetzt ein paar Jahre da, ist das anders. Dort kannst du beispielsweise schon frühzeitig sagen, ja, ich interessiere mich für diesen Karriereweg als Führungskraft und dann machst du schon Vorbereitungskurse, bevor es denn dann wirklich losgeht.
und dann wird auch nochmal geguckt, willst du es wirklich machen, wo gibt es denn was und wie und was.
Also das ist viel besser, die gesamte Einbettung der Leute da in diesen Positionen,
weil eins muss man dann wirklich sagen, so Teamleiter ist aus meiner Sicht die schlimmste,
also die, nein die schlimmste vielleicht, die stressigste und nervigste Führungsposition,
Hörungsposition, weil als Teamleiter bist du relativ weit unten.
Management-technisch.
Also da hast du eigentlich nicht wirklich was zu sagen.
Das nächste ist, du kriegst das Gemecker von deinen Leuten direkt ab.
Also deine Mitarbeiter im Team, kriegst du das Gemecker direkt ab.
Und du kriegst das Gemecker direkt ab von oben.
Das heißt, als Teamleiter bist du immer permanent so in der Zange.
Du kriegst von allen Seiten nur Gemecker ab, wenn es was zu meckern gibt.
Du musst unliebsame Sachen an deine Leute verkaufen und du musst Sachen, die wieder unliebsame Sachen an deine Chefs verkaufen.
Also Teamleiter ist eine wirklich Kack-Position.
Die würde ich nie machen wollen.
Deswegen kann man echt nur sagen, so Hut ab vor den Leuten, die das auf die Reihe kriegen.
Würde ich nie machen wollen.
Und für das, wie nervig diese Sache ist, kriegt das mein Chef echt gut hin.
bekomme seit
Juli 2014...
Aktuell ist es auch... Wartet mal, ich muss noch was trinken.
So.
Aktuell ist es wohl auch relativ
schwierig, von dem, was man so hört.
Aber gerade im IT-Bereich
wohl noch
ganz okay.
Mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Aber wenn du Physik gelernt hast...
Ich meine, dass keiner
dass keiner eine
Stelle Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration ausschreibt, ist dir ja wahrscheinlich
klar. Also, dass du danach so
Sachen gucken musst, wie
System Engineer, DevOps Engineer,
Site Reliability Engineer,
Server Admin oder sowas in der Richtung.
Hast du das ihm mal gesagt? Ja, ich habe ihm einmal gesagt, dass er der
beste Chef ist. Das hat ihn auch gefreut.
Was ist denn so dein Steckenpferd?
Was machst du denn besonders gern und kannst du besonders gut?
Also ich kann dir zum Beispiel sagen, bei uns im Linux-Bereich werden tatsächlich immer mal wieder Leute gesucht.
Aktuell allerdings nur für Einsteiger, was auch komisch ist.
Überall gefühlt sucht keiner mehr Einsteiger, aber wir suchen explizit Einsteiger.
Aber dementsprechend gibt es auch nicht viel Kohle für.
Wahrscheinlich suchen wir deswegen Einsteiger.
Nix mit Linux gemacht.
Ja, also Linux-Skills sind nicht verkehrt.
Aber ich meine, du hast ja sicherlich so ein Gebiet, was dich persönlich super interessiert.
Und in dem du auch richtig Ahnung hast.
Und da ist natürlich auch am besten, sich da was zu suchen.
Weil dann kann man das machen, worauf man Bock hat.
Und wird auch immer besser in dem Gebiet.
Und der Arbeitgeber hat auch was davon, wenn man einen hat, der Plan hat.
netto kann man immer nichts kann man immer schwer sagen klingt jetzt aber
jetzt nicht sonderlich viel ehrlich gesagt selbst wenn du das verdoppelt ist
es ja fast nichts also wenn du das verdoppelt und sagt dass dann in brutto
das wäre dann irgendwie 3900 euro brutto das ist ja nicht nicht viel ich meine
das sind mal zwölf es ist nichts selbst wenn man das wenn man selbst war 14 wäre
das vielleicht noch als mal 14 wäre das so am anfang vielleicht noch ganz okay
aber also ist das nicht vielleicht hast du aber auch pech und wohnst irgendwie
sehr ländlich oder in regionen wo es halt kaum jobs gibt kann jetzt nichts zu
sagen okay
gemeinde keck wait ja das kann natürlich sein dass es bei
die in der Ecke schwierig ist.
Was kriegt man denn bei E6?
Mindestlohn oder was?
E11 ist schon nicht so viel.
Ach stimmt, ja gut, im Osten ist es ein bisschen...
Aber guck...
3000 Euro brutto.
Aber das...
Ja, vielleicht Durchschnitt über alle Berufe,
aber doch nicht in der IT.
Das ist ja nix.
aber hier 3000 euro selbst wenn du das mal 14 rechtes 42 kam in 14 monats ist nix
für den job
also das ist was wo ich sagen würde als als einstiegsgehalt direkt nach der
Ausbildung kann man das mal
machen, wenn es sonst nichts geht. Ja, aber
das war es dann auch.
Ja, genau. Genau so sehe ich das auch.
Ja, dann drücke ich dir die Daumen, dass du was findest demnächst.
So, wir müssen das Video noch fertig gucken.
Fällt mir gerade ein.
Keine Ahnung.
Kenn ich mich nicht mit aus.
Laterale Führung.
Ein Team führen ohne Weisungsbefugnis.
Ich frage mich zwar immer noch, wie das gehen soll,
aber okay.
Interdisziplinär aufgebaut.
Wir haben da Personen im Team aus unterschiedlichsten
Fachbereichen hier.
Die sind alle auch unterschiedlichen
disziplinarischen Führungskräften
zugeordnet.
Das ist also quasi
quasi, ist das gar kein Team
in dem Sinn, das ist eher so eine Art
Projekt, wo man
aus unterschiedlichen Teams Leute
zusammengesetzt hat, also macht
der eher so eine Art Projektleitung
oder sowas? Sehen Sie irgendwo in mir
einen Leader?
Meine Notizen, Gerätemanagement ist eher
basic, lokaler Admin, nur Intune
Managed, Defender,
Bitlocker, wenig, ja ja,
Update-Dinge sind im Einsatz, alles
personalisierte Geräte.
Das war IT.
Ich muss mich leider ausklingen, ich muss einen Frage-
Nice of Cringe.
Fragenkatalog noch beantworten.
Und dafür habe ich mir jetzt nochmal gut 30 Minuten Zeit rausgeschnitzt, bevor dann um 14 Uhr der Projekt-Kickoff ist.
Jetzt schaue ich mir die Excel mal an und werde über jede Frage-
Excel, was sonst? Die IDE der Sekretärin.
drüber gehen
und mir überlegen,
kann ich die Frage beantworten
und was bedeutet es
für mich die Frage
simpel zu beantworten an Aufwand
und was bedeutet es für mich die Frage
Was Elmar muss eine Schätzung abgeben,
wie viel Zeit es braucht, die Fragen zu beantworten.
Der muss quasi
vorbereiten,
dass er dann arbeitet
oder was zum
Frage fundiert zu beantworten
an Aufwand. Welche Schutzmaßnahmen
gibt es gegen Hackerangriffe,
Schadsoftware und Phishing?
Ja, die können wir auch
beantworten, aber die kann
halt von einem Dreizeiler bis
zu einer 30-seitigen
Dokumentation alles bedeuten.
Und da muss ich mir dann eher noch ein bisschen mehr
Gedanken machen.
Ja, okay,
aus dem Gesichtspunkt macht es schon Sinn.
Wenn manche Sachen
umfangreicher sind, dass du dann im Vorfeld
sagst, das ist quasi sowas wie
Sprintplanning, wo man dann
guckt, okay, was kann man da jetzt machen?
Was packen
wir rein? Dass man quasi
schon schaut, okay,
das ist eine größere Aufgabe, das ist eher was
Kleines.
Okay, dann verstehe ich, macht
ja schon Sinn.
Den Rest kann ich nachher auch noch machen, das kriege ich hin.
Jetzt geht es gleich weiter mit dem Kick-Off-Termin, den ich von meinem Kollegen aus dem TIM vom
Bechtle Bodensee bekommen habe.
Viel weiß ich von kurz nicht.
Ich habe die Ergebnisdokumentation gekriegt, ich habe ein kleines Briefing vom TIM und
von der Projektleiterin bekommen.
Und jetzt lasse ich mich quasi überraschen.
Servus.
Danke für eure Zeit.
Bis dahin.
Ciao, ciao.
Kunde wirkt sehr angenehm. Da geht es darum, alle technischen Gewerke, die bei dem Kunden aktiv sind, unter einem Hut zu halten.
Hä? Was? Das war jetzt auch Beraterspeak, oder?
Ich gebe zu viel für mein Auto aus, aber es war es mir wert an der Stelle. Relativ hohe Leasingratenaufzahlung.
Ich habe einen Dienstwagen, den darf ich auch privat nutzen.
Den muss ich aber dann als Geldwertenvorteil versteuern.
Das wird von meinem Bruttogehalt abgezogen.
Zusätzlich dazu verzichte ich monatlich noch auf 534 Euro von meinem Bruttogehalt, um eben mein Wunschauto zu kaufen.
Oh, Alter! 534 Euro für ein Auto im Monat. Alter!
Da kann ich mit meinem Fiat nicht mithalten.
Gut, den habe ich ja auch nicht gemietet oder geleast oder so.
Den habe ich tatsächlich, das war so ein Vorführauto, gekauft.
Aber das ist schon ordentlich, ja.
Ist natürlich auch ein bisschen dicker als mein Fiat.
zu leasen.
Aber ich fahre es gerne und ich drehe mich gerne nach dem Auto um.
Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss. Döner, jawohl.
Ich habe echt lange keinen Döner mehr gefuttert.
Irgendwie habe ich da jetzt Bock.
Ich glaube ich hole mir heute Mittag
Ich weiß was ich mir hole
Ich hole mir heute Mittag
Ein
Pide Döner
Also das ist so eine Art Pizza
Mit Dönerfleisch drauf
Da habe ich jetzt Bock drauf
Ich habe in meiner Haushaltsbuch App
habe ich eine extra Position für Döner.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Ich habe ja noch Nudeln von gestern.
Die müssen ja auch weg.
Nee, dann doch kein Piededöner.
Dieses Jahr schon 900 Euro
für Döner ausgegeben.
Wenn du anfängst,
nach Gewicht abzukassieren, werde ich arm.
Danke dir.
Der Döner kommt jetzt in den Kühlschrank, weil ich mag den richtig schön kalt und durchgezogen.
Essen gegen Kostverhalt Geld.
Aber muss man mal sagen, da bist du mit Döner wahrscheinlich noch ganz gut dabei.
Überlegt man mal.
Der ist ordentlich groß.
ja.
Ich überlege,
was Sushi kostet.
Ich war letztens All You Can Eat Sushi.
Was habe ich nicht gehört?
Ne, habe ich nicht gehört.
Okay, ich scroll nochmal kurz zurück.
Was war?
Also ich war letztens Sushi All You Can Eat
essen.
Und das hat mit einem
kleinen Wasser 40 Euro gekostet.
Das war schon teuer.
Dafür habe ich auch wirklich alles.
Ich habe die so leer gefressen, ey.
Ich habe an die 30 Teller gefuttert.
Das sind so kleine.
So sah das da aus.
gibt sogar ein Bild, guck, so sah das da aus,
die sind da durchgelaufen, ich hab, das
ist ein bisschen, ist ein bisschen kacke,
weil hier oben, das ist, das ist, das ist
dreistufig oder zweistufig, hier unten
gibt's ein Band, hier oben gibt's nochmal ein Band,
hier oben laufen warme Sachen durch, hier unten laufen
kalte Sachen durch und ich
hab ungefähr 30
Teller in dieser
Größe gefuttert,
war, war, hab ungefähr eine Stunde,
Stunde da gehockt und
gefressen, ähm, hat sich wenigstens
gelohnt all you can eat.
Das war
Massive Paper Fat Time.
Ja, aber das nur
am Rande.
Der Döner kommt jetzt
in den Kühlschrank, weil ich mag den richtig schön
kalt und durchgezogen.
Jetzt weiß ich was ihr meint.
Alter Döner, dann noch irgendwie durch Nest und kalt.
Na gut, jeder was er Bock hat, ja, aber ich weiß nicht.
Wenn er dann Platz hat.
Fast alles an Kosten, an laufenden Kosten wie Miete, Nebenkosten, Versicherungen, Lebensmittel,
Urlaube läuft über mein Konto. Wir haben kein gemeinsames Konto, sondern Marleen zahlt mir
einfach einen Flatrate-Betrag pro Monat, mit dem sie ihre Kosten im Durchschnitt ausgleicht.
Ja, ich habe meine Fragen noch vor mir. Ich gönne mir jetzt.
Auf die...
Ja, als so Berater, das ist halt auch so ein Ding.
Du hast nie so wirklich
Feierabend, ne?
Auch ein weiterer Grund, warum ich aus einem
Beraterjob wenig Bock hätte.
Also, neben ganz vielen anderen
Sachen, warum ich das nie machen würde.
Ist das auch ein Punkt.
Die Fragen konnte ich
bisher auf 39
eine Antwort liefern.
Und ich denke, die anderen...
Sie wollen es aber wissen.
morgen mit zum Joggen. Dann kann ich mir morgen früh
noch mal ein bisschen Gedanken machen. Ich habe monatlich
ein Grundgehalt in Höhe von
6.500 Euro. Das bekomme ich fix.
Dazu kriege ich dann
nochmal 300 Euro
Abschlag auf mein
Jahresbonus. Also
300 Euro brutto obendrauf pro Monat.
Dagegen wird dann mein Dienstwagen
verrechnet. So komme ich
auf einen brutto in Höhe. Ach so,
das Auto kostet nicht für... Naja doch, doch.
Moment. Das ist ja
tatsächlich eine ganz gute
Regelung von 6445 Euro. Das macht netto 3925. Von dem Netto habe ich dann nach Abzug des Dienstwagens
und meiner betrieblichen Altersvorsorge und meinem Sportabo circa dreieinhalbtausend Euro.
Betriebliche Altersvorsorge lohnt sich ja eigentlich immer, wenn der Arbeitgeber was dabei bezahlt.
netto, die wir monatlich
eine Beratung oder so, ja,
freien Verfügung stehen.
Für mich lohnt sich das, ja.
Für mich lohnt sich das auf jeden Fall. Ich habe so viele Freiheiten,
ich habe so ein tolles Team. Ich stelle mich gerne
nach den Herausforderungen, die jetzt doch mal
unerwartet kommen. Ab zum Sport, ja.